hey how's it going bros my name is
welcome to fridays with pewdiepie
[Music]
what's it gonna be the memes this week
it's a tick tock
huh i thought you guys said you hated
tick tocks
well well where where where so i
actually got this in my feed i know
exactly what this is about
uh this guy made a tick tock with his
girlfriend
but it looks like she's kidnapped hey
everyone today is also my
birthday and because it's my birthday i
get to introduce you to my girlfriend
happy star
[Laughter]
i i don't know if i feel bad maybe uh
maybe she is kidnapped
but but a more plausible
uh scenario is that maybe she's not used
to being in front of a big audience
online and she's worried about what
she's going to say so she
keeps quiet you know but then tick tock
runs this whole meme right she's
completely also my birthday there
against her birthday i get to introduce
you to my girlfriend
star wars day everyone today is also my
birthday
and because it's my birthday i get to
introduce you to my girlfriend
awards day everyone today is also my
birthday it just keeps going it's my
birthday i get to introduce you to my
girlfriend
who is amazing today everyone today
i really thought these weren't funny
anymore but uh tick tock scrambled out
one last final breath
of reply it means i get to introduce you
to my girlfriend
everyone everyone today is also my
birthday marcus you don't want to do
this
let her go my girlfriend breaking news a
man is currently holding his girlfriend
hostage
police are outside of his home waiting
negotiation terms
breaking news a man is currently holding
his girlfriend hostage police are
outside of his home
i've seen more where the fbi rolls in
whatever you get the point
everywhere i go i see his face what
i don't get it i don't get it at all
creepy fact if you go to the bathroom
and say bloody mary three times you will
hear a voice saying i'ma whoop your ass
if you don't go to bed that sounds
exactly like your mother
holy [ __ ] tick tock is just too spoopy
there's too much truth in it my god this
is scarier than resident evil 8 my god
no i hacked into your account and found
secret tag
not the secret tape
i want your meatball recipe oh sh okay
well you can have that that's fine
delete it delete delete it delete the
footage
delete it now i mean i just love
meatballs
so do i we can be friends mr hacker
marzia if you knew felix pooped in the
shower would you still have meridian
awkward pause i don't really think so
she did not say that
she did not say that
what is the gift
oh god it's all gifts what has happened
to the subreddit no one asked uh i
guess i did [ __ ] first markiplier and
never seen them with
he's the daddy from marshall meet the
marshall that was a great film
emergency has fan art felix fanner there
you go
felix fan art hit different i love that
one that's one of the coolest one i've
gotten
i've actually taken a [ __ ] in the shower
once oh [ __ ]
all right now i get it now i get it well
you can't always find me
okay which one of you 19 year olds paid
for a rickroll ad
on piers video now that's dedication and
in a weird way i do respect it
forever faced wow i made a piece of
wedding ring but he never got to see it
well i saw now
don't get me wrong this is beautiful
right this is the best ring i've ever
seen in my life
obviously but can you imagine me
actually giving that to marzia
oh i didn't mean it i didn't life in a
bad way i just
she would love it it would totally
cancel out me pooping in the shower
the teacher explaining it versus the guy
on youtube
is this guy just a meme now what
happened while i was gone
there's gotta be a gun here oh wait
we're not in america american fans you
insulted my entire race of people but
yes i just want to make something clear
though like i
dog in america i don't in any country
because i know i have people watching
there so i thought it's funny
but some people always take it seriously
why is he making fun of romanians
i don't like it when he makes fun of me
it's a joke it's a joke
i don't mean it sure it's great i'm sure
you have a lot of guns in romania as
well okay i'm sorry
today i'm gonna show how to make super
fluffy
souffle omelette from japan i know how
to make 200 of these
hell yeah you found my comment
the thing is i was watching food wars
the anime and the guy makes 200 super
fast
and then i got this in my
recommendations i had to say it someone
had to say it
hell yeah this is what happens anytime i
show interest in anything
my entire audience is like that's cute
but here's how you actually do it
it's sick though
damn she's legit better than
the people in the competition that we
were actually like what the [ __ ]
very clean it's still big peeping now
put on some pants please
edgar is suggesting great to england
he loves it you're right mate video get
cracking mate
i'm an oc poggy now apparently mate
so cute though i need to get you that
hat again i get you right there
you're right there sleeping why are you
sleeping
you're making videos
why why do you disturb my slumber
hey guy you love you love making videos
with me tell them tell everybody
[Music]
go sleep stop sleeping it's swedish
uh-huh
sells chairs uh-huh it's swedish oh
heck look we're ikea aren't you excited
[Music]
look at this can you wake up a little
bit have some enthusiasm
you're supposed to be a youtuber i'm
depression
i sleep all day cause master doesn't pet
me
i'm so depressed oh
oh oh i don't care
hey
look at that again no not interesting
yeah all right
it's well pp edgar said small peepers i
i gotta listen
trade offer i get 110 mil you get pi
review
oh [ __ ] ah sh
did i tell i don't know if i remember
saying it but uh
i order a bunch of pies and they smelled
so bad that i was like i'm not eating
that
[ __ ] pies how's it going
bros oh it's so sick scythe do
face transplant hello
i am edgar hello edgar here
thank you side for your edits so epic
with lasagna
yeah i can't believe it almost has 300
300 million views that gary that's so
much
he doesn't care you don't care okay
you're really bringing down this video
felix wondering if you do it
yeah pretty much i know there's some
confusion because i said i had a sony
ericsson but i had the later
versions of the nokia okay you know the
tiny one
that one was super small that's the one
i had not the
3310 that everyone had marty said when
she overheard beard saying bruce willis
and tom cruise
are handsome dudes
what do you think is bruce willis
handsome
mr beast when a robber tells him to
empty his wallet jokes on you
i'm into that mr beast letting a robber
steal my entire house
that's the video life is all about a
second chance
what the hell do you mean what do you
mean this is the classic
i it's all been downhill from here get
out of here skidaddle
i'm just glad we're all on the same page
should we dip her in the sauce
eat the cha yes
dip her in the sauce don't worry edgar i
would never eat you
because your meat is not tender and your
brain is too small
there's nothing to eat when i first
started watching pewdiepie versus now
whoa baby
big peeping whoa that looks hella cozy
what the [ __ ] you have a better setup
than i do stop it
edgar get him go get him you're british
now get a knife and
stab them huge peepee love it edgar
become a surgeon now
edgar come on oh i got a phd in doctor
already and um everyone in the sub right
now hell yeah
oh yeah once you can flip one thing
clearly you can flip anything all right
egg are you ready for me to flip you
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
this dog does not care about anything
when he's tired
should we dip you in the sauce headgear
all right you know what i'll let you go
back to sleep
clearly now go stab someone
finally after 10 hours of surgery the
jpeg had been removed will they live
doctor
i don't know only time would tell we've
done everything that we can
the rarest gemstone paint night matches
the pewdiepie theme perfectly
i want it give it to me now that's
beautiful
i like it must be worth 3.99
that's a mean the name itself is perfect
pain
what the [ __ ] is this would you poop in
the shower like this
or like this i will not answer this this
is a trap
i refuse tall vampire lady from resident
evil 8
everybody yeah tall lady from resident
evil 8 just made everyone forget it's an
actual horror game
are you guys checking out the series
isn't it epic we're having so much fun
looking for items in the game
mere hours ago i was in a pdp video
yeah yeah yeah i'll praise it because it
was really funny
but i had to cut it out because it was
copyrighted music
and the whole video got cleaned because
of it i'm sorry
all right let's just take that it's
alpha oxtrot shout out big peepee
the thing is youtube systems and edits
the
clip out so it just goes to me saying
hey look at this really funny tick tock
and then cut the whole tick tock and
then wow that was really good that was
actually a good tick tock
and then no one got to see it
smart fella part smeller oh my god this
is
this is the level of right now i trained
you well i'm really proud
me coming out of my room to get my fifth
cup of gfyo hell yeah
the sustenance of life enter code
pewdiepie order pewdiepie drink today
change your life it will forever you
the guy she tells you not to worry about
[Music]
oh it's the 3d printer guy hell yeah
all right what do you got for this week
wow very double peepee very good
and you can brofist them out love it
austin did it again i'll give a big pp
seriously the furnace is
cool marzia years later i will avenge my
fallen children
that was the funniest bit that was the
movie where that looks i can meet the
marshalls
i was laughing my ass up [ __ ] furby
quoting nietzsche as well it's
great okay i want this
i want it now give it to me me after
trying to knife flip like pewds half my
respiratory
organs were destroyed what the [ __ ] is
this anime i've seen it so many times
that one piece
okay that's it for this week's friday
red pepper
see you guys in the resident evil series
having a lot of fun with that
check that out i'm streaming it every
day and
have a great week bye bye